[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
happy Tuesday everybody we'll get to the
indictments in the bidens in the next
block but first
so many stories
[Music]
could change your season be the reason
why
[Music]
some news
it's silly and stupid
[Music]
yeah it's true it's true in the summer
the news gets slower than AOC playing
Jeopardy
so let's talk about me I just got my
back waxed shout out to the Yankee
Candle Company
here's the before
I know and here's the after ah not bad
yeah thank you
those are my sisters but why did I do
this it's to make myself more attractive
if that's even possible but I wonder as
I get better looking what about
everybody else I believe it's time for
duckfeld scientific Institute presents
are people getting uglier
[Applause]
so is our imagination over active or are
people becoming less attractive it's
something that I've noticed go anywhere
and you see how Fitness has become
fatness meanwhile people take perfectly
good hair and diet blue or purple hmm
While others just let themselves go
but now science is proving me right it's
the theory presented by a fellow named
Shafi Hassan who apparently is a facial
analyst
a facial analyst sounds like the most
prized job at PornHub
actually Mr Hassan runs an Australian
facial Aesthetics consultancy firm that
uses artificial intelligence to analyze
people's faces in response to a question
about why old high school yearbooks
contain so many Attractive people
compared to today he writes quote the
average person's face is becoming
increasingly disadvantaged by modern
diet sleeping patterns pollutants and
oral facial habits creating a greater
inequality in the attractives versus the
unattractives so there you go as
predicted now even faces are
disadvantaged
maybe we can bust them onto more
attractive people
but if we're all getting uglier the damn
Democrats would call that equity
the sand breaks it down
have you ever looked at an old yearbook
from the 1950s and wondered why
teenagers or high schoolers look so much
older than they do today there are
multiple theories for why this is the
case but the one that makes the most
intuitive sense at least to me is
presented in contemporary Orthodontics
by prophet and colleagues using what's
known as the functional Matrix
hypothesis what get to the point weirdo
what is the functional Matrix hypothesis
in simple terms
in simple terms this theory states that
the development of the phase is
dependent on the forces that you put on
it for the upper and lower jaw with 70
of the western world having some kind of
malocclusion or recession much like this
it's a very good explanation for why
faces are becoming less and less
attractive as time goes on and much of
it has to do with the modern lifestyle
interesting so apparently we have less
pronounced Jaws than previous
generations because he's never watched
the WNBA
but also older Generations put more
force on their facial bones probably
from gritting their teeth you know and
fighting Wars and hunting wild animals
or dating Nancy Pelosi
now I think he might be right just look
at the average woman from the 50s talk
about beauty now what do we got
on the bright side you can open a Bud
Light on those jaw lines
let's look at the average women of today
no that's not fair you could apply this
Theory to men as well remember when men
looked like this now we're stuck with
this yep
there's so much estrogen in those dudes
just looking at them gave me menstrual
cramps
of course some will tell you that people
getting ghastly or is actually a good
thing if we want to control population
growth why not make ourselves
unscrewable or maybe it's a ruse to keep
us wearing masks forever
and the media says all bodies are
beautiful even when our eyes disagree
but there's been a rebellion against
Beauty which is felt in art and culture
biology heck think about how previous
generations used to dress in public to
go to a sporting event or take a flight
men and women would get dressed up a
full suit or a dress now it's all yoga
pants sandals and hairy toes
these days entire ad campaigns are built
around models you wouldn't look at twice
in a Walmart not that I've ever been in
a Walmart
well wants to buy a shovel a bag of lye
and a bone saw at three in the morning
but that's a conversation for later
but now we're told that our innate
disposition to find certain people more
attractive than others is actually a
form of bigotry called lookism even
though it's normal to be attracted to
people who don't look sick or tired
puffy and obese or all of the above
it's now discrimination to find some
people hotter than others or maybe just
maybe people look better years ago
because they took pride in their
appearance they had demanding jobs
instead of staring at tiny screens all
day they didn't Gorge themselves on crap
and then blame fat shaming and they
didn't waddle around in Crocs and
pajamas like they were inmates at a
mental ward it feels as if we as a
society have given up look at the cities
and entertainment and travel hell we
don't even expect our models on the
cover of swimsuit rags to be in shape
much less thin and when we're forced to
accept it as appealing it just doesn't
ring true so this isn't about ugliness
it's about a denial of Truth as Keith
said beauty is truth and truth is beauty
beauty or an aspiration for it somehow
always leads you to a truth about life
like Shakira said the hips don't lie
especially when they're in two different
area codes
[Applause]
when he's at a comedy club they make
sure all exits are clearly marked oh
some folks Across America Jimmy Fallon
liberals run for Safe Haven when they
see this political Maven former deputy
National Security adviser Katie
McFarland
her fiery rants make snowflakes with
their pants Fox contributor news
contribute
and he's never had to rent a forklift my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
so first off uh Jimmy what uh water bed
did you steal that sheet from
nice to see you too
give me some insight into why I do this
just really quick not really okay but
this is the deal okay yes I dress like
an affordable male stripper Would we not
all agree right
because it's 2023 you never know when
you're going to get canceled in this day
and age so you have to have a side
hustle lined up yeah like if you get
canceled you can make money at dwarf
torsing events the minute this is over
you show up they throw you you make 10
grand I don't have that option so I
gotta go with my tragic mic look but
nice to see you too now let me ask you
do you uh do you feel like you've been
discriminated against because of your
looks no not at all no not at all
because there's a thing okay first of
all when it comes to attractiveness
people aren't attracted to looks they're
attracted to energy okay everyone has
left a 10 behind at the bar to go home
with a six who had something about him
yeah I only know because I was the five
and a half masquerading as the six you
know what I'm saying but I thought you
were gonna say you were the five and a
half masturbating well it's a depending
on how the win home wins I mean maybe on
the front end but he's right to say
attraction has changed I know sorry
about that he's right to say attack
like my I'm 45 for real yeah my sixth
grade girlfriend still looks young I
mean it may change when she gets to
seventh you know what I mean but but the
point is this is why people have gotten
worse looking it's all because of
Instagram because there are so many
filters now everybody thinks they're
better looking than they are because
we're manipulating photos Instagram
should be called this is what I would
look like if I was hot and that should
be it
I think that's what we call alcohol boom
boom KT do you believe that we as a
society have given up I feel like if you
look at everything no one cares anymore
I mean I see people littering now I
thought littering was so 1970s
you know I'm married to a man who wears
a bow tie
and a cotton iron shirt to bed
time does get a little messed up oh yeah
I don't believe in standards but but
where does he where does he wear that he
got to uh dinner or uh
puts it on goes to play a little tennis
and goes to the desk fiddles with a tie
all good yeah wow so what are you trying
to say
um after 40 years of marriage I got kind
of used to it and so I'd be very upset
if he looked like the guy with the you
know shower sandals flip-flopping around
the house but do you think he's 80. so I
mean I guess that's something people are
people less attractive now than when you
were getting it when you people make
less of an effort yes it's more about
their own personal comfort and less
about the impression they give to others
you know as a woman who came of age when
women should be attractive but not too
attractive they should be hard working
but not too hard working it was a very
different errand now who cares right
yeah and that's a problem cat can't we
go back to the good old days huh I won't
say that to Tyrus
you know what he did he just told on
himself
good old days could have been like when
everyone sung songs and had candy
apparently with him it was when slavery
was fashionable
cat I defer to you
no that's great
um no I love looking really bad at the
airport I don't want to go back to the
whatever days of having a I look I I not
only wear sweats and don't put makeup on
and don't do my hair but I also never
take off my neck pillow yeah and I
posted a reel of myself at the airport
on Instagram and people were commenting
like a bunch of you know calling me like
ugly actually what they were saying was
I was Brave for posting that which is
like the meanest thing you can say
because it's like just my face but I
actually I think I don't care that much
you can't really hurt me by commenting
on my appearance I don't care because
it's gonna be changing all the time as
the years go on and I feel like if you
look good that's great but if you look
bad that's funny and that's something
that's even better plus you go somewhere
like LA and everyone's so obsessed with
looking perfect like you have everyone
has the exact same boob job the exact
same nose the exact same veneers
sometimes you know the girl with the a
cups and the overbite actually stands
out in this situation
there you go I it's weird though you
know okay so I'm a little older than you
Tyrus I don't know how much but remember
pharah Fawcett Cheryl Ladd Jacqueline
Smith our imagine like we when we were
growing up we wanted them do kids still
have that thing for like like an
aspirational hot beauty or is it all
just now Instagram models and see this
this report is very misleading because
they're taking out the X Factor because
we've always had bottom of the Barrel in
the food chain there's been ugly people
generational
and all Emperors there's been a group of
people that were just ugly and they
avoided pictures just for the sake of
everyone
they were polite about it
problem is now all the ugly people had
the cameras so it's switched it's like
the Dr Seuss all the stars don't want to
take pictures now good looking people
don't want to take pictures now because
they're not doing the shading and
they're not doing that stuff they don't
have to do it like cat says they just
are who they are at the airport and the
ugly people are ones saying you're ugly
they're because you don't have to put on
45 pounds of makeup four hairs and a
small child to go somewhere to look
better under the the guys the problem is
just normal good-looking people who are
too busy working and doing their thing
to take I've watched this go down I've
been at the Beverly Hills Hotel at the
pool people who don't have a room there
taking 9 000 pictures for one shot and
then when you see the pitch you go I
don't know man you're still ugly there's
filters
that's what it is good looking people
don't take pictures anymore it's all the
ugly people interesting I never heard of
that theater no that's a really
proliferation when's the last time gut
field you went on so you know what I
need a picture of myself today doing
something he just complimented me
because you'll buy it if I say it to you
yeah have you ever done that no I don't
take pictures of me ever thank you yeah
except a few times at the club
well we were buddies for a second
now the good old days thing sucks again
I just think attractiveness does require
diligence and discipline you want to
find out if you're attractive not take a
Polaroid yeah no filter you want to know
shake it and see if we see what you see
if you want to know whether or not
you're attractive ask someone to set you
up on a blind date because what they're
saying to you is this is what you look
like
not neces I don't know I feel like men
don't care how attractive you are or not
yeah we really but also no the men will
do anything so do you and then yeah so
or do you dress for other women or about
feeling good yourself or it depends like
right now I'm in my Fox News costume
yeah
so and in the airport I have a neck
pillow on right
well there's nowhere else to put a neck
pole you kind of kind of have to wear it
I see the girls on the street wearing
like the stilettos on the subway I'm
like you don't have to do that right
yeah it's hard to run trust me yeah in
New York you know uh so we got some we
got the big news up next of course hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else